we have officially moved into our new house
and honestly
I didn't want to show any part of this until it was all put together
because so often we see these new home tours and everything is immaculate
and you just wonder how the heck does their new house look so put together
but this is our reality
we don't have furniture we moved into this house owning nothing
and we purchased just the essentials that we need to move in
so we've got bar stools as a dining table
we have beds and just what we need to function
until we can afford to furnish the entire house and do with it what we want
and I think that is more of the reality of most people
than moving in and having your house look
picture Pinterest perfect right away
so here it is
here's our TV that doesn't have internet
no couches on to enjoy it
this is us